in the previous video we were able to
apply the binomial theorem in order to
figure out what a plus b to the fourth
power is in order to expand this out and
we did it and it was a little bit
tedious but hopefully you appreciate it
it would have been useful if we did even
a higher power a plus b to the seventh
power a plus b to the eighth power but
what i want to do in this video is show
you that there's another way of thinking
about it and this would be using
pascal's triangle and if we have time
we'll also think about why these two
ideas are so closely related so instead
of doing a plus b to the fourth using
this traditional binomial theorem i
guess you could say formula right over
here i'm going to calculate it using
pascal's triangle and some of the
patterns that we know about the
expansion
so
once again let me write down what we're
trying to calculate we're trying to
calculate a plus b
so a plus b
a plus b
to the fourth power
to the fourth power so i'll just do this
in a different color to the fourth power
so what i'm going to do is set up
pascal's triangles so pascal's triangle
so we'll start with a one at the top and
one way to think about it is if it's a
triangle where if if you started up here
at each level you're really counting the
different ways that you can get to the
different nodes so one and so i'm going
to set up a triangle
so if i start here there's only one way
i can get here and there's only one way
that i could get there
but now this third level
there are
if i were to say how many ways can i get
here well one way to get here one way to
get here so there's two ways to get here
one way to get there one way to get
there the only way i can get there is
like that the only way i could get there
is like that but the way i could get
here i could go like this or i could go
like this
and then we could add a fourth level
where let's see if i have there's only
one way to go there
but there's
three ways to go here one plus two how
are there three ways you could go like
this
you could go like this
or you could go like that
same exact logic there's three ways to
get to this point
and then there's only one way to get to
that point right over there
and so let's add a fifth level because
this is actually what we care about when
we think about something to the fourth
power this is essentially zeroth power
binomial to zero power first power
second power third power so let's go to
the fourth power
a fourth power
so how many ways are there to get here
well i just have to go all the way
straight down along this left side to
get here so it's only one way
there's four ways to get here i could go
like that i could go like
that i could go like that and i can go
like that there's six ways to go here
three ways to get to this place three
ways to get to this place so six ways to
get to that and if you have the time you
could figure that out
there's three plus one four ways to get
here and then there's one way to get
there
and now i'm claiming that these are the
coefficients when i'm taking something
to the so this is
this is if i'm taking something to the
zeroth power
this is if i'm taking a well not
something a binomial to the first power
to the second power and you might
obviously a binomial to the first power
the coefficients on a and b are just one
and one
but when you squared it would be a
squared plus two a b plus b squared if
you take the third power these are the
coefficients
third power and the fourth power
these are the coefficients so let's
write them down the coefficients i'm
claiming are going to be 1
and 1.
and how do i know what the powers of a
and b are going to be well i start a i
start this first term at the highest
power a to the fourth
and then i go down from there a to the
fourth a to the third
a squared
a to the first and i could guess i could
write a to the zero
a to the zero which of course is just
one
and then for the second term i start at
the lowest power at zero
and then b to the first
b squared
b to the third power and then b to the
fourth and then i just add those terms
together and i just add those terms
together and there you have it i have
just figured out the expansion of a plus
b
to the fourth power a plus b to the
fourth power is exactly what i just
wrote down
this term right over here a to the
fourth that's what this term is one a to
the fourth b to zero that's just a to
the fourth
this term right over here is equivalent
to this term right over there and so i
guess you you you see that this gave me
an equivalent result
now an interesting question
is why did this work why did this work
and i encourage you to pause this video
and think about it on your own
well to realize why it works let's go
let's just go to these first levels
right over here if i just were to take a
plus b to the second power
a plus b
a
plus b
a plus b
to
the second power
this is going to be we've already seen
it this is going to be
a plus b times a plus b so let me just
write that down a plus b times a plus b
so we have
an a
and a
we have a
b
and a b we're going to add these
together and then when you multiply it
you have so this is going to be equal to
a times a so you get a squared and
that's the only way that's the only way
to get an a squared term there's only
one way
of getting an a squared term
then you're going to have plus a times b
so let me write this so plus
plus let me write it this way
plus
a times b
and then you're going to have
plus
this b times that a so that's going to
be another a times b
a times
b
plus
plus b times b which is b squared now
this is interesting right over here
how many ways can you get an a squared
term well there's only one way you're
multiplying this a times that a there's
only one way
of
one way of getting there now how many
ways are there of getting the b squared
term
how many ways of they're getting the b
squared term there's only one way
multiply this b times this b there's
only one way of getting that but how
many ways are there getting the a b term
the a to the first b to the first term
well there's two ways you can multiply
this a times that b or this b times that
a there are
just hit the point home there are two
ways
two ways of getting an a b term and so
when you take the sum of these two you
are left with a squared plus
plus 2
times
a b
2 times a b
plus
b squared notice the exact same
coefficients 1 2 1 1 2 1. why is that
like that well there was only one way to
get an a squared there's two ways to get
an a b and there's only one way to get a
b squared if you set it to the third
power you would say okay
there's only one way to get to
a to the third power you just multiply
the first a's all together and there is
only one way to get to b to the third
power
but there's three ways to get to a
squared b
and you could multiply it out and we did
it
we did it all the way back over here
there's three ways to get a squared b we
saw that right over there
and there are
three ways to get a b squared three ways
to get a
b
squared and if you sum this up you have
the expansion of a plus b to the third
power so hopefully you found that
interesting